les faits se sont déroulés à l'avenue
jean jaurès aux terres sainville le 3
mai 2015 à 23h55 dans un bar de la place
bousculade altercation l'accusé claudio
espinosa aujourd'hui âgé de 31 ans sort
une avalanche et la scène pas moins de
treize coups de couteau à fabian richard
24 ans dont certains sont mortelles les
policiers et les secours n'ont pu que
constater le décès de la victime de la
première audition espinosa temps
d'expliquer son geste
il déclare que depuis la guyane fabian
avait proféré des menaces à son encontre
mais en examen pour meurtre
il est placé au centre pénitentiaire de
ducos dès demain il sera à nouveau
interrogé par les magistrats et les
jurés de la cour d'assises de fort de
france